for that. But go ahead. No, I was just
going to say um I was I've been doing a
lot of uh deep dive into a lot of
ancient Jewish beliefs and from what I
can gather that this idea of a
post-mortem sanctification of the dead
was highly highly regarded especially
the witness of Judas
Mcabas. Precisely. And he quotes Jewish
sources. He did a series on this on the
Jewish roots of purgatory. He mentions
that in second Mcabes is one of them
because second Makabes
1239:45 in some editions it's
123946. This is a Jewish book written by
Jews showing you that the Jews believe
that even those who
died you could still pray for them after
their death and offer sacrifices so that
any sins they committed that were not
remitted will be removed. So at the day
of resurrection they won't be condemned.
Yeah. Jewish source showing you Jewish
believe the Jews believe this, not
pagans. No, exactly. And I that's that
right there. It just blows my mind
because I again, these books were stolen
from me. I didn't grow up with these
books at all. You tell your Protestant
friend, "Without these books, how will
you explain passages such as these?"
Yeah. The the Isn't this the one about
Hanukkah where Jesus observes Hanukkah?
Yeah, I asked him this already and he
doesn't know how to explain it.
How do you how does Jesus celebrate
Hanukkah if it's if you don't affirm
second Mcabes with the rededication of
the temple when that is literally
Hanukkah and that's not in your 66 book
canon. Yeah. And it's honored by God as
a legitimate godly ordained festival. In
other words, it's one of the feasts that
God ordained that must be observed like
uh like Passover Yamipurum.
Why? In other words, you have God
ordaining a feast that the Jews now
observe like Purim, which comes out of
Esther, but
without a canonical warrant.
Meaning, why would the Jews go ahead and
honor a festival if it didn't have
divine sanction? But then if it did have
divine sanction, why would God not give
us an inspired record of it as he did
the other feast days?
There wouldn't be there there couldn't
be a reason. He if the law is true and
these are inspired feast days, there has
to be a record of it to prove to the
next generations that this was an
inspired feast day. Exactly. You see the
logic? He got it. Just like the the
purum which is the result of God
delivering the Jews from the
instigation of Hmon the Agai descendant
of Aag and Amalachite who lied in order
to get the Jews slaughtered and then the
king because of Esther's intervention
time intervention allowed the Jews to
arm themselves on that day to then
defend themselves and to kill those who
try to kill them and God ser preserved
them and then they honored that as one
of feast pur. It's called Purim. Yep.
Okay. And we have a now a divine
recording this event that God
sanctioned. Since Hanukkah is one of the
feasts that Jesus himself endorsed, why
would God not give us a
record that shows that this was divinely
sanctioned when he did it for the other
holy days? I even ask my father this
question a lot because he's still a
Messianic Jew who practices Jewish
tradition and they no one can really
answer this question. He he bounces off
of Jewish tradition. But I remind him
that in most Jewish traditions that if
you look throughout most of our
historical texts that we have for
recorded history, there has to be a
recorded documentation proving that this
feast day is an inspired and inspiration
of God.
Yep. So the whole point as he caught it
and he realized and he even got his
father to stumble. If you have a feast
sanctioned by God, well, you need to
know that God actually ordained this
feast, how you going to know it's
ordained by God if you don't have an
inspired record, written record showing
God ordained this feast? Because if
Mcabes are not inspired and they're
simply just books giving us history, how
do we know that these Jews were right
and adopting this as one of their feast
days? They actually call these a minor
feast day, believe it or not. Well, that
because what are you going to do once
rabbis are rejecting rejecting these
books as a response to Christianity?
Correct. They're going to have to say,
"Well, we we don't hold them in the same
regard as the other days, but they're
still feast days done less that they
observe." Right. Right. No. Exactly.
There's still feast days that they
observe in their lurggical calendars,
but they they have no record or
documentation to try and prove any of
this. Not to mention they've butchered
the entire feast day of Hanukkah as
well. Yep. But so you get it. Everyone
understand our Lord by observing the
feast of Hanukkah because that's what
dedication means is giving his seal of
approval as amen that this is an
divinely ordained feast.
However, for us to be assured, this was
an event of God where God interveneed
and was
pleased to ordain this as another feast
observed, wouldn't God give us a written
record leading up to the
inauguration of this feast? If so, where
is that written record? Cuz that's what
he did for the other feasts. But not
only that, there has to be a fulfillment
of this feast as well. Yep. And that's
our Lord because Hanukkah, the temple is
where God dwells. And believe it or not,
the day commemorating Hanukkah, it
was started and it was observed on
December 25th. Yep. And that was the day
that the incarnation happened. That's
the day that the Christians adopted for
the incarnation. Correct. Which makes
sense. Now, don't let anyone lie to you.
It wasn't the pagans who celebrated
December 25th and the Christians took
it. The historical record shows the
Christians were obser observing it and
the pagans adopted it from Christians.
Correct? So if you guys are not aware,
December
25th is the day commemorating Hanukkah,
25th. Is it ironic that the early
Christians adopted December 25th as the
birth of our Lord? Because that's when
Christ tabernacled pitched his temple
his tabernacle because the Bible tells
us that his flesh that he took from the
virgin is the temple the tabernacle of
God where God dwells in all his
fullness. John 1:14 the word became
flesh and pitched his tent tabernacle
among us. That's why he says destroy
this temple I raise it up three days.
And John says he was talking about the
temple of his body. And the Jews thought
he was talking about the actual temple.
Yep. That's their confusion. So any any
other questions, brother? No, brother.
Actually, I have to get to sleep. I have
a meeting for work in the morning. So,
God bless you, bro. Thank you so much.
Anytime. Pray for me, bro. And I'll keep
praying for you, man. Pray for me. I
need it, bro. I'm a sinner. I pray God
hears my prayers. But pray. I pray the
Lord hears my prayers, man. May the Lord
hear us both. Amen. God bless you, bro.